بينما يجتاح هوس باربي العالم خيبه امل
بسبب تاجيل الفيلم في مصر والسعوديه نجوى
كرم تدخل جينيس برقم قياسي ومهرجان
العلمين ينافس المهرجانات الموسيقيه
الكبرى في العالم العربي اليكم الابرز في
اسبوع
[موسيقى]
يواصل فيلم باربي حول العالم على مستوى
الايرادات بينما يجتاح ومبات يعرف في
تاثير باربي منصات التواصل عالميا فخلال
ايامه القليله الاولى في دور العرض حصد
الفيلم
337 مليون دولار في شباك التذاكر عالميا
ويمثل هذا الرقم اكبر ايرادات عطله نهايه
اسبوع افتتاحيه لعام 2023 حتى الان لكن من
يترقبون عروض الفيلم في السعوديه ومصر
والامارات شعروا بخيبه الامل بعد الاعلان
عن تاجيل اطلاق عرض الفيلم حتى نهايه شهر
اب اغسطس المقبل بعدما كان مقررا في 20
تموز يوليو دون ابداء اسباب واضحه لتاجيل
العرض
وعلى سيره الارقام القياسيه دخلت المطربه
اللبنانيه نجوى كرم موسوعه جينيس للارقام
القياسيه ما اثار نوعا من الجدل على منصات
التواصل فالرقم الذي ادخلها الموسوعه لا
علاقه له باي انجاز موسيقي وانما باطول
رداء في العالم وبحسب الحساب الرسمي
للموسوعه بالعربيه على انستجرام اجتمعت
كلام مع جماهيرها في العاصمه الاردنيه
عمان مرتديه رداء قياسيا بطول مذهل 55.7
متر وذلك يوم 27 يوليو 2023 لتصبح اول
مطربه لبنانيه تحقق لقب جينيس للارقام
القياسيه نجوى اعادت نشر الصور عبر حسابها
الرسمي على انستجرام وعلقت عليه بالقول
لما بنلتقي بيصغر الكون وبيكبر قلبي وكانت
نجوى كرم قد احيت حفلا جماهريا في الاردن
ضمن فعاليات النسخه السابعه والثلاثين من
مهرجان جرش للثقافه والفنون
[موسيقى]
كل المهرجانات الموسيقيه الكبرى في العالم
العربي بشكل متزامن حتى اواخر ابو اغسطس
المقبل كمهرجان جرش للثقافه والفنون في
الاردن ومهرجان قرطاج الدولي في تونس
والذي شاهد الاسبوع الماضي حفلا جماهريا
للمغني السوري ناصيف زيتون
[موسيقى]
وينافس المهرجانات الموسيقيه الكبرى عربيا
هذا العام مهرجان العلمين الجديده في مصر
والذي يستقطب نخبه من ابرز نجوم الغناء في
المحروسه والعالم العربي وحقق حفل راغب
علامه وناسي عجرم حضورا جماهريا وتفاعلا
كبيرين في الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
وكذلك تستمر فعاليات تقويم جده في
السعوديه وشهدت الاسبوع الماضي ايضا حفلا
للفنانه المصريه روبي اعتبرته من اجمل
حفلاتها
[تصفيق]
قلبي بلس